I'm scamming a scammer today but I won't
know if my plan works until the end of
this video because as I'm recording it
my plan hasn't really come together yet
so we'll find out what happens but win
or lose the point of this video is to
tackle one of my biggest pet peeves
which is scammers calling out other
scammers to make themselves look good I
guess the logic is oh I can't scam you I
call out scams and what kills me is that
it actually works people fall for this
all the time and it drives me crazy so
today I want to flip the script on one
of these people and attempt to have a
scammer call themselves out it's like
Inception but for con men we could call
it conception
Dylan danis is an MMA fighter famous for
two things cage fighting and not
fighting KSI but on December 23rd he
decided to be famous for a third thing
calling out the scammers he writes in a
tweet damn Logan Paul is a scumbag feel
bad for everyone he's scammed and of
course No One's Gonna really disagree
with this so the likes rolled in but
what Dylan doesn't tell you is he also
has a history of scamming people on
Twitter and what Dylan didn't know is
that there was a detective watching him
that detective was not me actually I
wish it was me it was my buddy Zach xbt
on Twitter who said damn Dylan danis is
a scumbag feel bad for everyone he's
scammed and then Zach showed some tweets
of Dylan promoting obvious scams which
then rug pulled now I was gonna kind of
leave it there a little nice Twitter
dunk but it got me thinking you know
deleted scam tweets are the internet
equivalent of roaches in your house in
both cases if you see more than one of
them there's a lot more you don't see so
I reached back out to Zach and I said
hey good tweet but I want to find out
how many scams exactly this guy has
promoted so Zach started digging through
the garbage bin of deleted tweets and we
found out pretty quick there were a lot
more but I realized it was going to take
Zach some time to get the results we
needed so we're going to go back to him
at the end of this video but right now I
had a bigger problem which is that to
show this full scheme I needed not only
the number of scam tweets I also needed
to know how much he got paid for all
this stuff uh for these scams he
promoted so even after looking through
the blockchain I couldn't find anything
so I needed a Social Engineering
approach to figure out how much he got
paid I wanted to trick Dylan into giving
me the amount the rough idea was to
approach Dylan and say hey I created
this dumb nft project that's completely
fake how much would it cost for you to
promote it he gives me an answer and I
have my price but of course I realized
he actually knows who I am because he's
tweeting about my crypto Zoo Series so I
can't contact him directly about this I
needed kind of someone who could reach
out on my behalf who like looked like he
would be serious about selling you an
nft collection and that's when I thought
of my buddy oompaville this is a guy
who's actually really sweet and real
life but his particular profile on
Twitter says nft salesman 100 percent so
I contacted him to contact Dylan on my
behalf and I told him to say hi Dylan
I'm launching a crypto nft platform
called sour.gg and was wondering what
your rate is for an Instagram story post
or Twitter post for promotion we can
provide all the marketing copy please
let me know as we're trying to launch
relatively soon now I guess as we wait
for him to respond let me explain that
sour.gg that website is not a real
crypto nft platform nothing in this
video is a crypto or real nft so you
cannot buy crypto for this I want to be
super clear as we talk about this not
only that the actual website we sent
them to is just a landing page for one
of oompa's candy businesses but it kind
of looks a little nft-like that like
there's like this little purple monkey
thing in the corner and so I thought it
would fool Dylan and I was actually
right because Dylan immediately responds
with want to do a tweet and then I I
love this next part what is it I like
the order of that you know like let's
promote it and then underneath it what
am I promoting uh and it's at this point
I realized that this is not only my
chance to find out how much Dylan gets
paid for all these scam promotions it's
also my chance to test Dylan danis he
says Logan Paul is so bad he feels so
bad for the victims but let's see if
he's so different so I decided that this
fake nft project I would be pitching him
was going to be just like cryptozoo in
fact to do this I basically copied
almost word for word cryptozu's white
paper saying the following sauer.gg may
appear to slowly function as an nft
collection but it's much much more sour
allows users to earn sweet tokens that
are openly traded via a yield that is
based on the Rarity of a given candy nft
but just in case you didn't think it was
obvious enough I decided to leave Dylan
one last hint I signed off with a
nonsense statement saying quote comma
obtain fun friends inter-exciting zones
indescribably Lush look out Adventurer
now this is a sentence which means
nothing unless you lay it out by the
first letter of every word and then it
spells coffee Zilla so uh don't say I
didn't warn him and obviously even if I
hadn't warned him Dylan Dan and Shirley
wouldn't promote a crypto Zoo project
right because he's you know he feels too
bad for the victims he wouldn't promote
something nearly identical oh wait he
said sounds dope and then eth question
mark and at this point I'm just a little
surprised by how easy this all is zero
due diligence is being done here we have
created the weakest facade possible for
an nft scam and he's just immediately on
board of course uh for a price I mean
that is the one thing he actually did
care about which might not surprise you
and it's the one thing he actually
pushed back on because I told him I
wanted to pay him a thousand dollars and
he said that's pretty low from
so he negotiated and landed on a payment
rate of five thousand dollars for a
24-hour post about our nft project which
does not exist after we settled on that
he sent me payment information which
really established a lot for us we got
answers to most of our questions first
how much he gets paid per post and we
also got an ethereum address from Dylan
which I hoped was going to link to all
his other payments but I didn't give him
enough credit here Dylan gave us a brand
new crypto wallet just for this
transaction which seems to imply that he
probably makes new wallets for every new
deal he does which is pretty shrewd and
at this point I realized I had a choice
to make I could take what I learned
present it to you guys and stop this
little charade I had with Dylan and make
my video and Dylan would just keep doing
this because his fans wouldn't know or I
could try to teach him and his fans a
lesson in a bit of a different way which
is actually pay Dylan to post a link to
our fake nft project but the twist would
be as soon as he posts that link it will
become a website dedicated to every scam
tweet Dylan danis has ever done and
remember that this website would be
linked by Dylan danis himself to all of
his fans directly showing them proof
that he'd scammed them multiple times
and we'll figure out how many times
again in just a second but I first want
to say I thought about this a while
because this plan has its own risks I
mean the number one risk is that Dylan
just doesn't post and steals my money
and then the number two risk is well
what if he finds out we duped him and
then immediately deletes everything we
don't get our money's worth so to remedy
that because I really wanted to do this
plan was to structure the payment so
that I paid him a thousand dollars up
front but didn't pay him the rest until
he kept the tweet for certain periods of
time and to my surprise he agreed to the
terms and so this is where I'm going to
leave things with them at this point I
have a lot of things to do before Friday
which is the day I told him this whole
fake thing is launching so I'm gonna go
do that and go get prepared for Friday I
will see you guys then
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen hope you slept well uh I
didn't sleep much at all we're working
really hard to get this whole thing
figured out so I'm just in the apartment
right here and uh we're gonna just get
ready together here uh because I got a
lot to tell you guys we don't have time
at the studio to get it all done so I
gotta prepare you here let me just set
the stage for you though for what's
happened since I last recorded number
one we created sours nft.com which is a
our actual fake landing page for the nft
project it's got all these cute
Candyland uh fake nfts that don't exist
now the idea is this is what he's
initially going to promote and then I
also created our little uh Switcheroo
website which is just a website with all
his uh previous transgressions now I did
talk to some people who were a bit
concerned that maybe I hadn't fully been
transparent with Dylan that maybe I
should be more transparent with Dylan
about what's going on so he doesn't say
I I trapped him in this whole thing so
what I decided to do just to make sure
we cover our bases here is I drew up a
contract for Dylan to sign before this
whole thing goes live I'm going to be
sending it to him and in it
I lay the whole thing out and this is
what I meant by headwinds this is where
he probably will catch us because in
black and white I lay out our whole
scheme right in front of him so it
literally says like you're gonna be the
butt of the joke it says people aren't
doing due diligence it says that we're
going to be switching the website to
show his prior promotions so we lay out
the whole thing there and what we're
really banking on is he's not going to
read any of this he's just gonna see
money and just sign it which is the
whole point of this entire thing so I
think it fits uh hopefully we don't end
up sabotaging our own project by double
checking you know covering our bases
here but either way that's what's going
on also Zac xbt finished finding all the
scams of this guy so we're gonna go back
to the studio and check those out
um all right I'm back and we have the
results from Zack xbt he found over 20
projects that Dylan promoted and then
tried deleting where many of them were
rug pulls and scams it was at this point
he just gave up looking for more because
there were so many so we added those to
the website but I'm sure many of you are
also curious about what's going on with
Dylan danis so we're gonna go check back
in with our liaison Oompa because at
this point the whole thing is set up and
it's all just resting on whether he does
any due diligence or not let's see what
happens tell us where we're at with
Dylan so he seems to have taken the bait
there's one final step obviously we have
to get him to uh to make the Tweet you
just sent ten dollars to him right just
yeah I wanted to bait him so that we can
send the contract and he's gonna be like
waiting for the money what now I mean is
is he responding he said sounds good and
then shortly after he said got it to to
saying that he he got the ten dollars we
sent as a test for the for his
transaction now comes the actual Moment
of Truth we were about to sit in the
contract oh my gosh
sending it all right and then I'm
sending the Drive Link I mean we've sent
the contract now we're just waiting
we're literally waiting Dylan
oh I agree bro I agree
oh what a idiot that's right
ladies and gentlemen he agreed and you
might notice that we weren't actually
able to use DocuSign and get his
signature because it was experiencing
outages at the moment the actual website
but we were able to just have him do a
written agreement in DMS that he agreed
to our terms and although it was very
shocking that he actually did it I have
to be honest it was here that the
pressure really ramped up because at
this point I paid Dylan a thousand
dollars and now we're just waiting for
him to post and I'm really worried that
what if he reads the document in that
time and realizes what's going on but
that's when Dylan gave us a lucky break
but also gave us a few curveballs okay
big news boys a little update ahead of
schedule by the way my heart like I
cannot take this I was already telling
up I was like we have to just go forward
with this because I'm not ready I cannot
take all the suspense and Dylan texted
us hey should I just go ahead and tweet
so we're just gonna say yes go ahead and
tweet it's refreshing now I guess see
what he says there's been so much much
work that goes into this you guys didn't
see this off camera Dylan starts talking
about where's your community so we have
to whip up this community from nowhere
our community doesn't exist we had to
create a Twitter profile we had to buy a
bunch of bodded followers an hour ago it
didn't exist I don't think I've ever
been so excited about something in my
life
tweeted it
I can't believe he did it he actually
did it he just tweeted it what an idiot
what hey
I can't believe it what can I say he
promoted a tweet which literally spells
out in first letters the word scam I
hope this has been highly educational
for you guys that most of these
influencers do zero work vetting these
projects contracts and nfts if you
enjoyed our work please consider
becoming a patron High effort
investigative journalism like this takes
a long time and a lot of setup but I
think you'll agree it's worth it I also
want to give a big thanks to both
oompaville and Zack xbt who helped me
pull this off please go follow them
because they're helping us get to the
point where influencers will wonder when
they take these deals in the future am I
agreeing to be the butt of a joke and of
course the answer to that question when
you're Shilling nfts is always yes so
anyways thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next one
foreign
[Music]